quest'estate
guarda che è il vino no niente che
domani vado al forze che le caselle per
capito ci vado quando sono piccola
quindi cioè non è niente di che per me
c'è la piscina olimpionica la
massaggiatrice personale però capito non
stacco mai totalmente capisci quello che
intendo poi vorrei sardegna dove vuole
ma esiste qualcosa e sardegna a porto
cervo mamma ma non è che sia di essere
snob e che rischia di siamo tutti lì noi
che facciamo girare l'economia
il massimi turche fatto in sardegna e
porto cervo e porto rotondo per andare a
casa di silvio
ma cos'è capito amore madama sono amici
di famiglia silvio mio padrino
poi però d'agosto si riempì di tamar e
quindi ce ne andiamo tutti da capri
piazzetta noi non sono mai state in
piazzetta non sono neanche messa
attaccata in realtà no perché permette a
prestare in barca davanti a capri
comunque non è capito che sono solo
circondata la gente falsa la gente
schifosa che se vuole approfittare poi
non è neanche vero che è meglio piangere
su una ferrari perché i ferrari sono
data amarvi è molto meglio piangere su
una bugatti